hello everyone i'm rich stocks in 1997 i
heard a cassette tape by dr joe wallach
veterinarian and physician the title of
that message was dead doctors don't lie
dr wallach's book and audio dead doctors
don't lie now has sold hundreds of
millions of copies all around the world
it has become the most popular health
lecture in history not only did i begin
following dr wallach's nutritional and
wellness advice i also began sharing his
message with everyone i knew
and 25 years later i'm still sharing his
message i'm still following his
nutritional guidelines and i'm excited
to share it with you today the full
audio lecture dead doctors don't lie is
available free of charge on our website
mineraldoctor.com
mineraldoctor.com we have two other
websites that might be of interest to
some of you i am also a bible teacher so
for bible teaching we have rich
stocks.org
rich stocks.org
and for those who are interested in
reducing maintaining and controlling
their weight
we have simple3slim.com
simple com
simple3slim.com
on the
mineraldoctor.com website right there on
the homepage the first two things that
i'm going to recommend you do number one
take our free health evaluation
this will save you a lot of time and
effort and money and experimenting you
take that health evaluation then
schedule a free phone consultation with
one of dr wallach's associates and they
will help you
to pinpoint your nutritional
deficiencies and find products that best
support what your body is lacking today
i want to talk to you about dr wallach's
three steps
to better health
three steps to better health number one
identify the category the health
category
or the tissue that's breaking down now
if you haven't seen the video before
this one we talked about dr wallach's
nutritional deficiency chart and the
four health categories
this will make a lot more sense what i'm
sharing today
will make a lot more sense if you
watch that video first or for sure if
you'll go watch it after you watch this
one we saw there are four health
categories and almost all the diseases
in the world almost all yes there are
viruses and tick bites and snake bites
and different things but most of the
health challenges
that people are suffering with fall into
these four health categories and here's
what they are number one
hard tissue problems
number two
soft tissue the heart tissue problems by
the way that's your bones your skeletal
system soft tissue problems
that's your organs your eyes your skin
your
your heart your lung your kidneys
the organs of your body number three
blood sugar problems and number four
digestive problems so the first step to
better health to be honest is taking
that free health evaluation
that's how you're going to determine
identify the category
where you need the most nutritional
support
that's how you're going to determine the
tissue in your body
that's breaking down
you may have
symptoms problems in all four categories
well a lot of times that's a digestive
problem you won't know for sure
until you take
you may know you have problems but you
won't know the full scope and how to
best address those nutritionally
until you take that free health
evaluation all right so that's step
number one identify the problem we could
say
step number two these are dr wallach's
three steps to better health
step number two use the appropriate
health pack
and the appropriate dose
we tell people this
if you will take all 90 again that's
another video the doctor walks message
is 90 essential nutrients you see it
where is it right here on my shirt 90
for life what does that mean 90
essential nutrients that every human
being needs from preconception that
means before you were even formed in the
womb
up until the time you die that you leave
your body
you need 90 essential nutrients
there's no exception
this is everyone needs the 90 essential
nutrients
so if you will take the 90 essential
for a minimum of 90 consecutive days
that doesn't mean you get to stop
but that is a good test period to see
well is dr wallock's message true
and then we can help you with your
absorption that we'll talk about in a
moment but if you'll take the right
products but here's a catch the right
dose
now dr wallach does this differently
from anyone that i've ever listened to
most nutritional products if you read on
the bible on the bible
i am a bible teacher that'll help you as
well by the way but if you'll read on
the bottle of most nutritional products
it goes by age in other words it says if
your up to the age of four or if you're
between the age of four and 12 or if
you're over the age of 12 or dr wallach
does not do it that way
he was a veterinarian before he became a
physician so let me ask you this
if you had a german shepherd
and you had a chihuahua
and you took them to the vet
and they both needed the same medication
and they're both the same age
let's just say they're both born the
same day
would that veterinarian give the same
dose
of medicine
or nutrition
or food or anything else would he give
the same
dose to your german shepherd as he would
as he or she would to your chihuahua
well of course not
it just sounds ridiculous doesn't it
but yet this is the way
most people do nutrition they go by age
doctrine wallet goes by body weight you
could have a child you know there is an
obesity epidemic among children now
you could have a 10 year old child who
weighs 300 pounds
you gonna give them the same dose
as an adult
my mother at the time of this recording
is 93 years of age and she's less than a
hundred pounds now
you're going to give them the same dose
of well of course you wouldn't age has
nothing to do with it
nothing to do it goes my body weight
so if you'll take the appropriate health
pack and let me just go through those
again real quickly so for hard tissue
problems
you take the 90 essential nutrients
that you see right here you can get
those in three products the reason you
see four products we give you the option
the calcium product you have to separate
it because you need so much calcium you
don't just mix it in with all the others
you separate the essential oils because
oils and liquids don't mix okay so
that's why there are three products you
can't get everything you need in one
product but you can get everything you
need in three products
so why do you have thousands because
some people need
much more of certain nutrients in
addition to the 90 essential nutrients
so
healthy body start pack three products
you get the calcium and a powder or
liquid powder or like either one that's
why there's four so here's your healthy
start pack if you add this product
called glucogel
now
you have
the healthy bone and joint pack
healthy bone and joint well that
addresses hard tissue problems okay if
you take your healthy body start pack
and you add
extra essential fatty acids and you add
extra selenium
now your healthy body start pack has
become the healthy brain and heart pack
to help support and promote soft tissue
problems okay
then for the blood sugar problems simply
add one product that we call sweetes
take your healthy body start pack
add the sweeties we call this the
healthy blood sugar pack well guess what
it does helps to support
and promote healthy blood sugar and that
addresses
the blood sugar deficiencies then the
fourth health category is digestive
problems
so you take your healthy body start pack
you add extra enzymes
to help you break down and absorb your
food and
extra
probiotics this is flora fx friendly
flora friendly bacteria put that
together and you have now the healthy
digestion pack that's how that works
okay and again we have a full video
dedicated just to that so we're talking
about dr wallach's three steps to better
health step number one you identify the
problem what category do i need the most
support in
step number two you use the appropriate
pack i just told you and the appropriate
dose that's why it's so important
to not just take the free
health evaluation but also schedule your
free phone consultation so that one of
dr wallock's associates can help you
find a pack that number one meets your
budget
and number two
that's according to your body weight
that and if you'll do that my friend
you're going to be very very happy with
the results and then step number three
is simply this
we call it clean up your diet
now a lot of people think cleaning up
their diet
somehow replaces nutrition
well we've gone through that you need to
watch the other videos
eating organic does not add one bit of
nutrition to your diet
say are you down on eating organic no i
do it now years ago i couldn't afford to
it does cost more but i've convinced
myself i'm worth it so it doesn't bother
me to spend the money you should never
be
afraid or concerned about spending money
on yourself
how much is your house worth well my
health is worth more to me than my home
i have a nice home
now i'm blessed i'm happy about that
but my this body my physical health is
of greater value to me than my house so
i should be willing to pay for my
supplements at least as much on a
monthly basis as i do my house payment
or my car is your car worth more than
your home don't ever be afraid to spend
money on yourself if your health is
important to you okay so but my point
here is that cleaning up your diet
will not replace one not one of the 90
essential nutrients
what will it do it will help you absorb
more of the nutrients you're taking
so here are dr wallock's
three steps to better health number one
you identify the problem the category
the health category where you need the
most support
number two you take the appropriate pack
and the appropriate dose according to
your body weight
and then number three
you clean up your diet
you start eating foods
that help maximize absorption and you
avoid the foods that hinder absorption
now our next video we're going to talk
about that the next video is dr
wallick's good food bad food
list we're not going to do that here
today
we are out of time but i want to
encourage you go to our website
mineraldoctor.com you can read
about these products in detail the
labels say well what ingredients you can
actually go and you can look at the
label you can see exactly what's in
every one of these products
but more importantly when you go to
mineraldoctor.com be sure that you take
those two steps
take that free health evaluation
schedule that free phone consultation so
we're out of time for today but we are
looking forward to hearing from you
very soon